Ede lib is being bombed and burnt into
surrender and it's civilians many of
them children are in the way of an
advancing army the broken bodies of
young boys working at this repair shop
are brought out of the wreckage a father
goes through his son's pockets to
retrieve any last memento even if it's a
set of keys yg was also there but
somehow survived he's a mass of bandages
after being showered with concrete when
the bombs fell his swollen fingers are
filthy with dirt and blood but he can
still move them YG's father is a rebel
fighter but it's his son who's paying
for his refusal to support the Syrian
regime and at just 11 years old what she
has already seen a lifetime of blood and
death these shocking images we showed
you earlier aren't even that unusual in
it Lib tiny children being terrorized
carried to safety by volunteer medics
derided as terrorist by the Syrian
government we trace the children to
their third home in as many days where
they've been reunited with their father
it's telling that seven-year-old Renaud
is so familiar with the words of war
[Music]
[Music]
initially the weather is shockingly cold
now making the lives of the hundreds of
thousands who fled the bombings and who
are now living rough even more wretched
Alex Crawford Sky News